new revelations from Apple confirm what
many iPhone users suspected Apple slows
down older phones
the reason the lithium-ion batteries in
aging devices can't keep up with peak
demand for power apple says the
batteries may eventually need to be
serviced or recycled and a werner is
here with details of the slowdown that's
frustrated users and a good morning good
morning Anthony you know just like my
iPhone yours is probably storing
hundreds or thousands of photos dozens
of apps a lot is required of these
phones these days now Apple is being
accused of slowing its devices down on
purpose a computer scientist we spoke to
says it's happening because the iPhones
power problem is widespread
we've now sold over a billion of them
this makes iPhone the best-selling
product of its kind in the history of
the world your web browser will be
slower instant messaging will be slower
your camera will be slower basically
it'll affect almost all the
functionality of your phones say for
actually making phone calls when John
Poole a Canadian computer scientist set
out to figure out why the performance of
his wife's iPhone seemed poor he says he
made a surprising discovery in order to
sustain the life of its device
he says Apple is deliberately limiting
the power the battery sends to the
phone's processor which runs apps and
other functions at this point in time
the only fix is to replace the battery
Apple now confirms it's been slowing
phones
it says the issue began when its iPhone
6 experienced sudden shutdowns last year
older batteries were struggling to keep
up with the phone so the company offered
a limited battery replacement program
and a software update the company now
admits that updates load the phones down
in a statement to CBS this morning Apple
says our goal is to deliver the best
experience for customers which includes
overall performance and prolonging the
life of their devices Apple could have
made a statement and said this is what
we're doing but Paul says he's
frustrated that Apple wasn't more
transparent should a thousand-dollar
smartphone have this sort of issue you
know 12 16 18 24 months after it's been
shipped given their statuses
premium phone in the market it's
disappointing well now you can solve
this problem by replacing the battery on
your phone if your device is not under
warranty however Apple charges $79 for a
new battery the company says the that
this impacts all lithium-ion batteries
in the industry but pool told us in his
testing other mobile phone brands do not
seem to be experiencing these issues but
to note I did replace the battery in
this phone last year
no $80 fix the problem any other seems
like a good trade-off compared to
spending eight hundred nine hundred for
another fat's what I figured
yeah annoying what kind of genius what
they're doing hope there thank you very
much